(zipper closing)
(dramatic music)
- [Narrator] Pop quiz.
Who is this?
If you answered Olympic gold
medalist freestyle skier
Jonny Moseley, you are
correct. It is Jonny Moseley.
- Hey, I'm Jonny Moseley.
- [Narrator] Here's another question.
What exactly is Jonny
Moseley doing right now?
It's strange.
It's as if Jonny is figure skating
on skis.
What you're witnessing is a rare glimpse
of a lost athletic art
that was once the pinnacle
of freestyle skiing.
It had judges.
It had costumes.
It had fans.
It had a name.
Ski Ballet.
(dramatic music)
In the beginning, young freestyle
skiers didn't just want
to ski down, they wanted
to ski fun and invented
a new sport that would
eventually make it all of the way
to the Olympic games.
Ski ballet was born.
- Yeah, it just looked like a bunch
of crazy stuff on skis.
- [Narrator] This is three time
world champion skier Bob Howard,
a legend in ski ballet when the sport
was in its 1980's heyday.
- What they didn't know
then, we don't know now.
Ski ballet is very difficult.
I'd like to demonstrate,
but my knees are shot
so I brought in Jonny Moseley.
- I'm Jonny Moseley.
- They know.
Ski ballet was a form of freestyle skiing
and it had a couple of
different incorporations:
it had pole flips, spins, linking tricks.
We put it all together
with rock and roll music.
Early on we did some moves
that were basically flex tricks,
where you go off your tips.
And what it is, is you flex your
tip up and you spin around.
Those are pretty difficult
because you're balancing
and you can hurt yourself real quickly.
You can dislocate your knee in an instant.
Here's Jonny doing a 720,
which is two times around.
We copied this from ice skating
and it even goes to a higher level,
where it goes to a 900,
which means he spins around
two times and lands backwards.
(crowd cheering)
- [Narrator] The lights in ski ballet
were never brighter than when
it was a demonstration sport
in the Olympics in 1988 and 1992.
But ski ballet was not
long for this world.
The spotlight dimmed when
the games dropped it in 1994,
and the whole sport went
fully dark not long after.
- The DNA of ski ballet
is actually in everything
that freestylers today, all the spins
and moves you see in the
slope style and the big air.
We did all that from the very beginning.
That's why I teach my
students ski ballet moves.
"I'm gonna do it, come to
a stop and I just pull."
Oh, that hurt.
- [Narrator] So the next
time you're on a chair lift
and you spy Jonny Moseley down below,
clad in a retro onesie and
painting a ski masterpiece
on a canvas of virgin snow,
take a moment to realize
that you're glimpsing
the flight of a phoenix.
A phoenix called ski ballet.
(dramatic music)